Silver State Schools Credit Union the
sponsors of this next segment know that
the holidays are right around the corner
and they are giving back to both their
members and the community I sat down
with president and CEO Scott a Arcos to
find out how
welcome back to the show CEO of Silver
State Schools Credit Union Scott a r
golf great to see you Scott thank you
Mercedes
we love talking to the people over at
Silver State Schools Credit Union
because they make our lives so much
easier but not only that you guys are so
committed to our local community what
are you guys doing to give back this
holiday season yes Mercedes so as you
know service day Schools Credit Union is
always committed to giving back to the
community we just wrapped up our
clothing Drive last week and I wanted to
thank first of all everybody who donate
donated items to this great cause and
this week we started our annual food
drive to benefit students at our local
Focus schools so anyone can help our
food drive by donating items at any one
of our 10 branch locations uh throughout
the Las Vegas Valley and in Henderson
and we're collecting canned and
non-perishable food items now through
November 19th you are always always
helping out the community it's so great
and another great I can't believe the
holidays are right upon us and I know if
people want to maybe benefit from their
shopping this holiday season Silver
State Schools Credit Union can help out
with that
yep I'm glad you asked Mercedes uh so
Silver State Schools Credit Union is
offering an amazing cash back rewards
credit card program that actually pays
back 1.5 percent in cash back on every
purchase every time and we've got
competitive rates and no annual fee um
in fact I put us up against anybody uh
from for our rates and so
um you can apply today and you can earn
cash back as you make those holiday
purchases so I just wanted to make I'm
sure that people know too all lines of
credit such as credit cards are subject
to credit approval first but for more
information you go to Silver State
schoolscu.com
backslash cashback
now I know there's a lot of people
watching like that sounds great but I'm
not a member and I'm not a student or
teacher and it's easy to qualify for
membership you don't have to be a
teacher or student to become a member
right Scott yeah not at all it's a it's
really a common misconception Mercedes
that we only allow Educators uh to
become Silver State schools credit union
members
um it's not true almost anyone can join
uh the credit union so parents qualify
just as an example for membership
because their children are students with
no age restrictions at all so that's one
of the many ways anyone can qualify for
membership for other ways to qualify or
to become a member just visit one of our
physical 10 branch locations that I
mentioned uh throughout the valley and
in Henderson
um or go online again to
silverstatecu.com it really is easy to
become a member I was surprised at how
how incredibly easy and fun it was so
crowd member right here Scott thank you
so much great to talk to you we
appreciate you Mercedes thank you
thank you to Silver State Schools Credit
Union for sponsoring this segment call
702-733-8820 or visit silverstatecu.com
for more information